when who BAE's party chief spoke to the
media two weeks ago he must have known
his days were numbered Jian Xiao Liang
is the highest ranking political
casualty so far his dismissal is in
response to mounting public anger over
the Chinese government's handling of the
corona virus outbreak and follows the
sacking of two senior health officials
on Monday and while the purge looks set
to continue analysts say it won't bring
down those at the top of the party the
way the Communist Party works is
sacrifice a few small fry to keep the
big fish swimming in the pond and and
this has worked I mean this is what
happened in the last great time of the
SARS epidemic 17 years ago the dramatic
jump in deaths came after a team from
the World Health Organization arrived in
Wuhan the head of the w-h-o has lauded
China's containment efforts including
the isolation of 60 million people and
urged countries not to cut off travel
and trade with China
health officials say the reason for
Thursday's sharp rise in death and
infections is because the testing
criteria has been broadened Chinese
virus experts say the epidemic should
peak in China this month before
subsiding what officials don't know
though are the number of people who've
not been tested because they're either
unable or unwilling to visit overwhelmed
hospitals the government continues to
put out a reassuring message to the
outside world that it has this virus
under control and facing it we have
always adopted an open transparent and
highly responsible attitude not only for
the sake of China but also for the world
at large state TV is stressing the
positive showing patients who recovered
and gone home
it's all reminiscent of the Mao era with
a mass mobilization of medical workers
volunteers and soldiers the nation's
being encouraged to fight war President
Xi Jinping calls a people's war against
the Devils
virus and there's another virus his
government is trying to contain growing
calls to protect freedom of speech an
online campaign led by academics who are
demanding an end to media censorship
seems to be gaining momentum that
amounts to explicit criticism of the
leadership which is rare in today's
China in Hong Kong as in mainland China
the death of dr. Lee Wong Leung has
increased that anger he raised the alarm
about the virus six weeks ago for doing
his job he was reprimanded by police and
forced to sign a humiliating confession
he died from the virus on Friday
President Xi Jingping has offered
condolences to the families of medical
workers who died but he's yet to
publicly mention dr. Lee by name Adrian
Brown al-jazeera Hong Kong